if you're feeling a bit salty today that
may be because this is national tortilla
chip day and to help celebrate is chef
anthony irve from ghost donkey uh and
for those welcome first of all
for those who are not familiar with
ghost donkey this is kind of a speakeasy
inside
right right so cosmopolitan yep yep so
exactly ghost donkey is hidden on the
back of block 16 so it is clearly marked
with a door with a donkey on it and you
might struggle a little bit to find it
but once you find it you'll be very very
very impressed with how good looking the
place is and all the creative options
and really the vibe is like so unique in
it and one of the specialties of course
is nachos along with cocktails you have
a hundred plus cocktails there right
right right so uh we feature over like
100 different mexican spirits uh it is
truly a brand based on mexican
hospitality so we feature super
innovative cocktails and uh like i say
over 100 bottles of mexican spirits from
tequila to mascara and and uh who better
to talk about the mexican restaurant
than the french guy right yeah so the
ultimate experience uh today i'm going
to show you it's uh the truffle natural
so in my opinion it's clearly one of the
things that everyone at the cosmopolitan
should try so it consists of a warm uh
corn tortilla chips like you can see
here with uh or classic bechamel on it
or twist to it is we add a little bit of
like shaved truffle to it okay so it's a
classic french sauce sauce with a
mexican twist for the nachos so this is
already this is definitely that's that's
not done actually so um as you can see
it is the chips and the cheese and the
sauce i'm adding some
cotija cheese
some chives
nice and uh i'm getting raw my sieve
as well as the nachos
no so we do um we do like guacamole and
we do uh salsa
those type of things um so it's a great
night place right right right yeah
so a lot of fresh truffles to it
um and we finish it with a little bit of
a truffle oh nice i'm going to dig that
into the ultimate experience right now
that is fantastic
and then uh
tequila lovers in particular and would
appreciate what you have to offer right
absolutely like i said like the
the cocktails are so innovative so
creative you know really based on like
mexican small artisanal bottles and
production so really really worth it
very creative these are fantastic by the
way ghost donkey started in new york is
that right right area origin it was
originally created in new york and uh we
opened our location about three years
ago at the cosmopolitan um so yeah
but the the origin of ghost donkey is
one of those names it's just a fun name
right it's just a fun name really
there's really no very but nothing
behind the name but it's uh
like i said it's a brand based on
mexican hospitality you know to feature
like a small artisanal bottle and super
extensive selection of mezcal and
tequila and uh the naturals man like
it's really the style of the show that's
what you want to come for i just i just
looked and and did i ever interest you
as deangelo
uh d'angelo that's what i think i said
in the beginning but saying oh no no no
no he said yeah anthony yeah yeah sorry
all right we're gonna call you by the
right name now antonio really appreciate
it and if you haven't had a chance go
visit ghost donkey inside the
cosmopolitan
more to come